cette petite entreprise ne connaît pas
la crise radis noir poireau alpha
luzerne et bien d'autres graines sont
ici mélangés dans une ambiance chaude et
humide pour tirer le maximum des graines
à germer
cette partie de l'entreprise a été
touché par la crise sanitaire car très
dépendante de la restauration
à l'autre bout de la chaîne l'atelier
germé sec
là c'est tout autre chose sur l'atelier
germé céréales de petit déjeuner on a on
est quasiment obligé de travailler en 3
x 8
en ce moment nous travaillons en 3 x 8
c'est à dire qu'on a une équipe de nuit
et deux équipes de jour ce qui
permettent de faire face à la demande et
on est obligé également de compenser en
recrutant du personnel intérimaire ou
des cdd
la société distribue aussi des germoirs
et des sacs de graines prête à germer
qui cartonne auprès des enfants pendant
sept ans le compliment ça se passe
plutôt bien c'est quelque chose qui est
dans l'air du temps les gens font germer
les graines chez eux et ont leur propre
récolte de graines à germer
on fait ça en famille c'est plutôt
ludique est assez marrant de voir la
graine germée pousser mais le plus gros
atelier reste le soufflage et la
déshydratation des graines pour les
céréales du petit déjeuner un nouveau
marché en très forte progression + 35 %
depuis mars qui ouvre les portes de la
société berrichonne à l'exportation
avant la prochaine révolution pour
l'entreprise on est amené à réduire la
consommation de viande et à se tourner
vers des apports en protéines d'origine
végétale et la famille de graines qui
s'y prêtent le mieux c'est la famille
des légumineuses ce qu'on appelle les
légumineuses les lentilles et les pois
chiches les pois verts les haricots qui
sont des graines donc qui offrent
vraiment un potentiel de développement
très important
en accompagnement de ce phénomène de
changement des habitudes de consommation
des légumineuses que germe line trouve
sur le département du cher dans le cadre
d'un accord avec des agriculteurs locaux
en circuit court